SESEOKING AROUND, UNSURE WHO TO
COVER. ARE STILL BODY CHECK.
SAVED BY SAROS.   THE BAR.
THE PUCK STAYS OUT.
REMAIN SCORELESS.
THE LAST
30 TRILLION.E COMING
DOWN.
TRANSITION PLAY.
PLAY A TREMENDOUS JOB BY
DOESN'T GET THERE.
BLOCKED BY JOHNSON.CROSS.
THERE GOES.
SAVED BY SAROS.
HUGHES . PUCK HAS
THIS BREED   THE SUPPORT
THAT. THE DEVILS
AGAIN.
I SHOT , JUST WIDE.END BOARD.
ON PURPOSE.
ROMAN JOSI HAS BEEN ROAMING ALL
OVER THE ICE.
HE'S BEEN A FIRING MACHINE.
HE FINALLY GETS ONE TO GO.
SI IS THE LAST ONE YOU WANT
TO LEAVE OPEN.
HE'S AVAILABLE ON THE WEAK SIDE
AS THE PLAY MOVES GHES.
SAVED.
GREAT CHANCE BY HUGHES. 9. HE S
MANY GOALS.
SAVED AGAIN.
BY SAROS.   BIT OF
TIME  FOR HIM  -- BLEEDING.
STITCHES..
THAT HAS BEEN A FANTASTIC LINEF
REBOUND.
TRYING TO COVER IT UP. I WOULD
SEE --
>> John: SHOT.
WHAT A SAVE  BY
HE'S GOT TIME TO BURN HERE.
>> AJ:
RUNNING AROUND OUT OF THE
STRUCTURE.
THAT TURNS